- So y'all, do you all have
any over drinking stories?
Maybe for daytime.
- For daytime?
- For daytime TV?
- Yeah.
- You know us.
- That narrows it down.
- I heard that your most drunk moments are
with Blake Shelton.
- Yes, somehow,
- Cause I'm gonna be honest with you,
I think it was your story
that I have an identical story
with my bed and my
husband holding my hair.
Cause Blake is the enemy
when you are drinking.
(audience laughing)
I had just started drinking
cause I'd had a baby
and it literally.
- This probably was
her first over drinking
- I had never really gotten
sick from drinking and so
- [Kelly] Boy, it's fun.
- And it was Blake's fault
- Blake kept handing her
- He kept handing me things
- Like Irish car bombs and I'm like, Dude.
This is not going to go well.
- So I
- Ronnie Dunn does that too.
- That's right there.
So I got to the bus and I was like
I've never felt that feeling
of spinning or you know.
And I got in my bunk and
laid down and Jimmy goes
you should put one foot
out of your bunk and try
- [Jimmy] Ground yourself
- Try to settle yourself and
then Kimberly, she's so sweet.
She opened my curtain, she goes
You want a peanut butter sandwich?
(audience laughing)
Then I said, yeah I do.
I don't feel very good.
And then I woke up the next morning
and the peanut butter sandwich
is laying next to her.
- It didn't quite get there.
- So thanks Blake.
Sorry mom and dad.
- Yeah, its a revelation.
- I blame Blake and Ronnie Dunn.
I'm like wow,
my worst alcoholic experiences
involve those two men.